I'm Sophie leard and today I've been
challenged to break down gift wrapping
into 11 levels of
[Music]
complexity as we go through these levels
just remember this is going to take some
practice so don't give up as a
disclaimer this is my interpretation of
the challenge level one box and bow
we're going to have three versions of
this level we're starting with the box
and bow because it's the easiest one to
master it's also probably the one that
people would use the most so a box is
the same measurement every time the
paper should go just over halfway up the
side and then cover the top of the gift
that's how you would measure and this
applies to all sizes I don't worry about
whether my scissors are cutting a
straight line or not I will just tidy It
Up by folding the edge of the paper over
before I start wrapping just straightens
everything out you're just going to
cover the box from left to right over
the top just a little bit of overlap add
a piece of tape here fold the sides
in until you get to your last side of
the box for a box I'm just happy to use
standard tape so when you're doing a
ribbon you have one long side and one
short side to make sure you measure it
correctly
[Music]
without cutting the roll
first so here's another method it will
measure exactly the same but it will be
a different technique on these
side tidy It Up by folding the edge of
the paper over left fold right
fold tape and then then when you get to
the sides you're going to fold a
diagonal line and then crease your sides
and that would make your box look super
super sharp just make sure your paper
really hits the side and the same when
you're going in now you're going to take
the paper right into the box before you
crease fold up tap you can decorate it
with a nice bow it feels natural for me
to hold it top Corner short side holding
with my thumb you're going to go over
one corner then under the next then over
the next Corner then under the next and
that should bring you back to the middle
another thing that helps with bows is if
you keep your Loops really small then
you can always make them bigger
afterwards this is like when you found
that one present you haven't wrapped and
you've got one tiny bit of paper left
and it doesn't fit and it's not the
neatest of wraps but it's that I'll go
to the shop so we will do this you're
just going to turn it on an
[Music]
angle and then it should fit it's just a
great way if you've just got a little
bit of paper left and youve still got a
gift left it's quite likely that a box
will fit if you turn it at a diagonal
next up level two sweater the difference
with dealing with a box versus a sweater
is that your box has nice flat hard
sides that we don't have on clothing so
to fold the sweater you're going to fold
in the sides and fold down the arms and
then fold the bottom up and then fold
the
top folding with tissue is my absolute
fave if the tissue paper is too small it
doesn't matter you just layer it across
on the table overlap your second piece
and it will still wrap in exactly the
same way what you're going to do first
is just fold the paper over the the
sweater and then tuck in each of the
ends into the
sweater level three the book so the
books are a higher level because you can
do quite complex wraps with them just
purely because of the shape they're kind
of a box but they're very flat we're
going to have three versions of this
level the paper should go just over
halfway up the side I just measure it by
lining it up with the side of the
book
it's going to come right over the book
like this so after we've measured out
the paper the first fold is to make your
card
slot it's essentially just quite a big
pleat and really from there on you can
just wrap your book as we've taught you
in level one right fold left fold add a
piece of tape Fold It Down fold
[Music]
up card slot and and you can decorate it
with a nice
bow with the second book wrap we've
changed the shape of the card slot same
kind of measurement as number before
you're going to fold a diagonal line and
then fold up the best paper to use
especially if you're starting get some
wrapping paper that has a real abstract
pattern on and that way you're not going
to have to worry about whether the lines
are straight this is the front of the
gift so you want to put the bottom down
first because then from the top this bit
will sit that way and if you do it the
other way you'll be able to see it from
the top the detail my bottle as you say
retail is
detail and then use a corner bow which
will sit flush against the shape of your
card slot and just all ties in really
nicely pleating can go many places you
can make your pleat any width you like
it's not quite the right size you can
open your paper back up and replete I
mean I do that all the time if you're
just starting with pleating I would
recommend starting with vertical pleats
and practicing with those and then you
can change to diagonal pleats which are
really fun it's nice to keep your pleats
nice and tight I'll just turn it over we
don't want to see the tape we don't want
to tape on our beautiful pleat so we use
double-sided so it's hidden underneath
the wrap tape that down and then you
wrap the
sides level four stocking stuffers so
things that work really good for the
gift wrap method is items like this so
they've got shape here and then a shape
here I would definitely be wrapping
little cuddly toys in there just because
look they're just an awkward shape so
you're going to fold the paper into
thirds and to measure it just make sure
your paper covers the gift that you're
wanting to put in the bag we use
double-sided
tape then you're going to make the
bottom of the bag by folding the paper
up and then pushing in the
sides tape then you're going to move to
the sides of the bag you're going to
fold those in so they meet the corners
of the
bottom then you're going to fold it all
out and making sure you put the gift in
the bag you can then start to close your
bag up you're going to fold a diagonal
right and then left
[Music]
and you can decorate it with a nice
bow tape here so multiple items cuddly
toys awkward shapes also tiny things
like Cosmetics they're also really
really difficult to wrap you can make a
little gift bag and put all three in the
gift bag as well level five cubes so a
cube all the sides are the same area
with the boxes that we did a level one
there was always one side shorter than
the other so it's a slightly different
type of wrap if you going to wrap your
cube with a standard wrap then you would
absolutely use the same measurements as
a box which we showed you in level one
but for the top of the box we will need
some extra paper so we've just cut a
little bit extra for the top of the box
create your shapes by folding the paper
into the
[Music]
middle start with one side you're going
to fold up you'll do this for all four
sides you just go around your Cube and
folding in the middle fold into the
middle and it just gives you this
beautiful kind of like a fire swirling
shape on top of the cube that's
perfectly symmetrical level six box with
no tape to start with the no tape method
you do need to get the right
measurements and this time you're going
to measure on a diagonal and make sure
the corners go over the top of the box
on both sides it's definitely easier to
use a thinner paper so shop bought paper
you need a lot of flexibility in it what
can go wrong is so many things for me
personally it's usually the measurements
if you've got the measurement just too
wrong not just slightly wrong that's
absolutely fine but if you've got a
massively wrong measurement of paper it
will make the wrap so much harder you're
going to start with one corner and just
make sure it comes over the box and it
just hits those top two corners and then
to start the sides you're going to run
your nail from the box all the way out
and this is just to give the paper some
creasing and that will make it a lot
easier for you to then do your next fold
and the next fold you're then going to
fold the sides in and fold your next
Corner over the box and you're going to
repeat this on the following corner
until you get to your last side of the
box
level seven cookie tin this will work
for all cylinders this level think about
pillar candles maybe anything that's
that type of shape but you've got a
cylinder and then a flat top and a flat
bottom so you're going to measure the
paper should go just over halfway up the
sides
tape my tip to make sure all your plates
are the same size is just to use your
finger in between each plate when you're
pulling the paper towards the center
just remember you're repeating the
action turn your shape repeat but use
your finger to get the pleat the right
size if you want a bigger pleat then
you're going to put two fingers down if
you want even bigger you can put three
it'll just help you get really even size
pleates all the way around once you've
done your first one just repeat it on
the next one repeat on the next one and
you'll get it beautifully the same until
you get to the
end level eight the candle this is just
fun yeah and quite often candles have
got funny lids or they're kind of going
out in a funnel type shape so this is
just a great way to wrap it up and make
it look really
fun we've got the shape that we need to
start with one side and then fold the
bottom up the tricky part is definitely
cutting the corners so you get the right
shape to be able to tie the ends with
your Ribbon I quite like to clas myself
as a home gift wrapper so kind of like a
home Baker everything with wrapping can
be trial and error can be practice and
you can start again level nine the wine
bottle I feel like with the wine bottle
I mean we give wine as a gift so often
there's no way to wrap this without
knowing we're taking wine so I tend to
encourage people just to wrap it as the
wine bottle tissue paper is the easiest
to use when doing the wine bottle and I
would highly recommend using
it I held on to it I mean you could at
some point tape it I guess but it's nice
to keep your pleates nice and tight and
even if it does fall it's easy to put
back together that's the beauty of
tissue
[Music]
paper we're using a bow we're using
pleat so there is some technique
involved and it let's face it it's a
very odd shape but it's a gift that's
given often so it deserves a little wrap
level 10 soccer ball I just realized how
i' never say that word level 10 football
yeah this was super unusual and I
appreciated the challenge on this one
you've not only got a sphere but you've
got it in a triangle box whoever
designed this obviously didn't want it
to be gift wrapped so it's a slight
variation on the gift bag this level it
just has a little bit different finish
so you're going to fold the paper into
thirds then you're going to make the
bottom of the bag by folding the paper
up making sure you put the gift in the
bag the way we turned it on its side
it's just a completely different shape
but the premise is the
[Music]
same level 11 tennis racket I love a
challenge and I thought okay so what
shapes have we got so what we do is we
break down the tennis racket into
different shapes and what we've got is
the top of the tennis racket with the
strings which is a round shape and then
we've got the bottom which is kind of
like a pole I would say what I would
think about is wrapping the top half
first and then moving on to the bottom
half using the same paper but two
separate sheets and then bringing it
together we actually pleated the top
half of the racket which I thought
looked very
[Music]
lovely and then we brought the paper
down to the
bottom and then we used part of the gift
bag method to be able to wrap the handle
of the tennis racket because actually
the handle isn't quite a straightforward
shape neither round or has sides so the
gift bag method was a really good one
and then we just were able to connect
them
[Music]
together I think it just turned out
really
nice I hope for anyone who gets all the
way to level 11 I really hope that you
take away the repetitive techniques that
you can use for the different shapes and
that you can see when you pick up your
next gift what technique you can match
to wrap that gift and if you don't get
it first time or you don't get it second
third or fourth time know that that's
happened to me too and practice makes
perfect thank you so much for
watching